now
all right we are live and getting set up
we already have somehow uh over 40
thumbs up on this video let me check to
see if we are indeed live
on the into the impossible podcast
Network
where I am being joined
by my good friend and many Time guest
and that is Professor Avi Loeb of
Harvard University Avi you're looking
tan you're looking sharp uh I want to
ask you so many questions my audience
has so many questions but first of all
how does it feel to get your sea legs
back being out on the open ocean how was
that
well I enjoyed it I used to jog every
morning the only surprise was I I joke
at Sunrise and suddenly I noticed from
my workout app on my watch the time some
days I I jog the slower than usual and
some days faster and then I figured out
that it's actually measuring the speed
of the platform that I'm running on and
that's the ship that I was on fittingly
called Silver Star I think I'm probably
the first to recognize that you can't
really measure your speed when you're
jogging on on a ship because the GPS
system gets full
that's right yeah I I I was able to walk
across the Atlantic Ocean last week on
my way back from Paris and London uh but
the only way I could do that was on an
airplane so uh but we're going to talk
about things that traveled much much
faster than an airplane and those are of
course uh the fragments from a very
interesting and mysterious object that
you have uh discovered identified and
are beginning to get samples returned
and I understand uh FedEx deliver the
meteorite was delivered by gravity uh I
believe but the uh but the samples were
delivered by you uh by FedEx so show our
uh viewership please Avi if you would
what you have in your hand the most
precious metals on Earth perhaps
well um I I decided to share the
materials with three Laboratories mainly
at Harvard University uh we have a
laboratory with the best instruments in
the world
but also with UC Berkeley and the broker
Corporation in Germany that has some
x-ray fluorescence analyzers that nobody
else has and when I shipped the
materials to Germany I had to declare
what is inside the box and I said sand
and then I had to declare the commercial
value of it and I said no commercial
value it has
enormous scientific value of course yeah
and you know it took millions or maybe
even billions of years for this material
to arrive to Earth by the way it was not
a matter of gravity it just bumped into
the Earth as a result of its trajectory
which crossed the path of the earth and
it came actually from behind the Earth
it was moving at 45 kilometers per
second uh and it came just as the Earth
was orbiting the Sun from behind the
Earth if it were to collide with the
Earth head-on if the Earth for example
if you were to reverse the motion of the
earth it would have collided with us at
90 kilometers per second very fast and
outside the solar system it was moving
at 60 kilometers per second which is
faster than 95 percent of all stars in
the vicinity of the Sun so here is an
object that made its way in interstellar
space faster than 95 percent of the
stars in the vicinity of the Sun now
that material is very precious I have
some material which is very precious too
this is a fragment of a stellar solar
system meteorite which was found in
Argentina and you can enter to win it if
you click this link or in the show notes
I have it brianking.com mail and if
you're a member of the audience that has
a DOT edu mailing address you will get
this guaranteed so the rest of you
non-edu and that's because obvi I want
to see myself as an educator right so I
want to get access to Young Minds while
they're fertile and they can do the most
good and we have the most uh free energy
to to use their powers to benefit the
Earth and I think a lot of what you're
trying to do with this and your upcoming
book which you've graciously provided me
with an advanced copy of called
Interstellar that is uh as part of your
mission too education so well actually I
wrote 36 diary reports from the
Expedition and they were read by
millions of people over
um the couple of weeks that I was in the
Pacific Ocean they were translated to
Spanish I received a large number of
emails from people who said that it
improved their understanding of how
science is done because often what they
hear about are in press conferences
where scientists lecture to the public
the final results and that's very
different from the process of doing
science where you are confronted with
partial data you don't know what to make
of it and by assembling more data you
get to the bottom of it just to give you
an example we had a sled that was
scooping the ocean floor one day it came
back in one of the runs covered in white
paint it looked like a Jackson Pollock
painting
and I thought well maybe it bumped into
a can of paint that one a sailor dropped
from a ship but then I took my finger
took a sample of it put it in a vial and
we studied the composition the chemical
composition of this quote unquote paint
ended up being biological and then we
Googled it and found that there is
indeed uh this kind of gooey stuff that
you can bump into at the bottom of the
ocean so here is an example you first
think about a conjecture it turns out to
be wrong Based on data that's the way
science is done and people really
appreciated that there was even a person
from Denmark that wrote to me that he
had a stroke for four weeks ago and as a
result of reading my reports he
developed a desire for for a living you
know like he got a new sense of why life
is worth living and that was very moving
to me that science can can provide
people with a meaning as as long as you
are honest and straightforward about the
scientific process you are not
pretending that you know everything in
advance and people connect to that
people connect to the uncertainty
whereas scientists very often remove the
uncertainty they want to just talk about
things that are finalized in a final
format and we all know that that's not
the way science is made that's not the
way the sausages you know to to be
polite and but respectfully disagree
oftentimes and you pointed this out to
me many times they don't talk about
things that they're certain about they
talk about things they speculate about
as if they are certain about it so I
can't tell you I was just had the
opportunity and a huge honor of speaking
at the Royal Institution the longest
ever ongoing lecture series started by
Michael Faraday as you know back in the
18 mid 1800s and uh and there most of
the questions were about wormholes and
black holes and I don't know why people
are so obsessed with holes in the
physics Community but string theory and
inflation and all these things that you
have worked on by the way but um but to
say that we speak about things and it's
all nice nice and neat sometimes that's
true I think we teach our students when
I teach a lab class I'm teaching an
experiment that won the Nobel Prize you
know in 1963 you know something like the
Davis and germer experience you know
some some pre-packaged canned experiment
I know it's going to work but oftentimes
what you hear about in the media from
your colleagues in uh in theoretical
physics mainly obvi I have to say not
you but but many of your colleagues and
we know who they are we won't name them
but they speak about pure speculation
with the certainty of fact so no need to
respond to that but here is the here is
my frustration which touches on yours uh
a week before I went on the Expedition
which is pretty much an experimental
Endeavor we are we were just trying to
figure out the materials that made up
this unusual meteor that we mentioned
that was discovered by U.S government
censors back on January 8th 2014 so
almost a decade later we are looking
searching for materials from that meteor
and my colleague a colleague of mine
came forward and said look man any of us
think that you will not find anything
that it's a waste of money a waste of
time and why do it and I said I'm not
asking you to do anything
uh you know I'm doing the heavy lifting
I'm going there and you can just sit
back and relax and if I don't
oh one second honey from your dark
matter research in fact the money that
funded this expedition was a donation by
a person who would not give it to
science otherwise and so it's a win-win
situation I don't understand the
negativity about collecting evidence
which is pretty much the scientific
method and why would a community of
scientists or some scientists object to
collecting evidence or have a bad
feeling about it after all that's what
science is about it's not about
speculating about extra Dimensions or
not finding supersymmetry after
investing 10 billion dollars in the
Large Hadron Collide that's not new
knowledge new knowledge comes with
collecting evidence for whatever you're
seeking
now your new book which we'll get to in
just a bit is considered with
extraterrestrial life not necessarily
just extraterrestrial technology I say
just but I don't mean that negatively
okay so here is an anecdote related to
that when I was jogging one day we had a
filming crew of a documentary and they
uh fill me with from a drone that was
looking at the ship from a distance and
then at the end the director came to me
and said it looks like you are running
are you running away from something or
are you running towards something wow
and I said both I'm running away from
some of my colleagues
and I'm running towards a higher
intelligence in interstellar space
so we'll talk about life in just a bit
because I think I've come up with some
Notions maybe speculative but some ways
that we can use kind of the reverse of
what's Happening Here where where an
impact has occurred on the Earth from a
Interstellar trajectory at 99.99
confident 99.959 whereas I'm kind of
interested in the reverse in other words
if a meteorite Interstellar or not hits
the Earth blasts up uh some of the uh
some of the surface and it hits it in a
region of the Earth's surface which is
populated by that same bacterial sludge
that you found or whatever it was or
stromatolite or perhaps it hits uh you
know uh you know some some high-rise
building and it blasts into space some
genetic material right so that should be
floating around our solar system I have
a fragment which I'll give you when you
come to visit me as you promised and
I've promised to visit you too but I
have a fragment of Mars which cost you
know many many you won't get a fragment
of Mars if you join my mailing list but
but it costs a lot of money not as much
as your Expedition but it costs a lot
and that means that there are particles
of the Earth on Mars correct so oh yeah
definitely what can we say and then and
of course there are many
um objects that come from Interstellar
space but it's only one in a thousand of
the rocks or the objects that come from
the solar system that
um you know that may have originated
from Interstellar space so most of the
the vast majority of all the impacts on
Earth are building blocks of planets
like the Earth that are floating out
there like Lego pieces and that's the
one you held in your hand the difference
is that those that come from
Interstellar space may be quite
different and I should say this
particular meteor we know from the
analysis of the fireball data that the
government provided that it had the
sustain remained stress far greater than
all other space rocks that were
cataloged by NASA over the past decade
272 of them so irrespective about what
it's made of arguing about the details
the point is that it had material
strength above all the space rocks that
we often see from the solar system and
that raised an interesting question you
know maybe it's made of some artificial
alloy uh and maybe it was moving very
fast just because it had the benefit of
artificial propulsion and so of course
if we imagine Voyager that's a mission
that we send to Interstellar space in a
billion years from now it could collide
with an exoplanet and burn up in the
atmosphere as the meteor and of course
that would be an unusual meteor of a
higher material strength than natural
rocks and also could move faster than
most of the interstellar objects I guess
my question is uh kind of the inverse of
that is it possible that such a deadly
meteorite hitting the Earth blasting off
our surface as the regolith I have from
from Mars demonstrates could it carry
some remnants of DNA or even life is
that possible this is called panspermia
now in terms of um you know how long can
life survive in space there are
estimates in the literature it's highly
uncertain mostly estimates extend the
lifespan to maybe 10 million years not
more than that because the material is
exposed to cosmic rays and without any
nutrients or liquid water it may be
difficult it may disintegrate and so if
it's only 10 million years you know
traversing the Milky Way galaxy at
speeds of tens of kilometers per second
require you know half a billion years
and so if we're talking about a journey
that lasted for a half a billion years
any living organism would not survived
that long at least based on of the type
that we are familiar with it will just
disintegrate so but on the other hand if
it's uh for example equipped with
artificial intelligence if it has some
Machinery that was technologically
produced you can imagine that lasting
for much longer than a living organisms
and and of course that is a completely
different matter yeah I'm actually
asking you know whether or not the
non-observation of life in our solar
system so the non-observation of life so
far on Mars is that not possible in sort
of a Drake Equation fashion or maybe
just a Bayesian estimation can we limit
the probability of the existence of life
outside of our solar system another the
fact is that Mars had liquid water on it
we believe it had you know potential to
support you know a microbe you know
airdropped onto Mars two billion years
ago could have survived potentially but
can we not say something about the
overall global odds I've never seen this
I've seen the Drake equation
I mean what we know is that Mars had has
a lower surface gravity so it couldn't
retain its atmosphere and a couple of
billion years ago it lost its atmosphere
now before that it had liquid water on
the surface and whether what forms of
life it had we don't know and that's
part of the mission of the NASA Rovers
that are being sent
frankly I mean personally I believe that
we have a better chance of finding
traces of Penny early life on Mars in
the caves in the so-called lava tubes
which are these caves that are
underground protected from postmic rays
and are not really affected by the
extreme temperature variations on the
surface after the atmosphere was lost
and I'm particularly interested in going
into these caves the lava tubes and
searching for any wall paintings because
maybe intelligent life developed on Mars
twice as fast as you did on Earth you
know a factor of two is not a big factor
and of course today they would not be
able to survive there is no atmosphere
all the liquid water evaporated but if
they existed we might find some wall
paintings and uh and and moreover we
might find some skeletons in these Lava
Tubes so that's my personal interest
going with a drone into these lava tubes
and examining them
we cannot say at the moment uh how to
calibrate you know we cannot say whether
there was a Life on Mars and how
advanced it was uh until we find any
traces of it just one thing to keep in
mind even Suppose there were cities on
the surface of Mars you might say oh we
don't see any high rise well the point
is that any square kilometer of Mars was
bombarded by 20 Hiroshima atomic bomb
explosions associate triggered by
asteroid impact I I calculated that in a
couple of billion years you basically
get 20
Atomic explosions per square kilometer
and any high rise would be demolished as
a result of that so not to speak about
you know any living creatures
um and obviously without an atmosphere
or liquid water they would have a hard
time surviving yeah well reportedly
inside one of those lava tubes on Mars
the scientists discovered four words
etched on the walls of the tube do you
know what they were Avi it was it said
please like And subscribe so if
everybody is out there and you're
interested uh first of all I put up
avi's medium site on the screen you
could go over there Avi Dash lobe at
medium.com and of course you can win a
meteorite if you go to Brian keating.com
Mail and uh I first want to start off
with some images so I have an image here
I always like to joke about
um you know it's it's uh it's a very
interesting image I'll just pop on the
screen you won't be able to see it but
it's meteor crater Arizona have you ever
been there Avi
I don't know I've seen images of it so
if you remember the images there's a
huge uh you know one you know plus
kilometer crater uh and then I always
joke you know it's so cool that it
struck right next to the gift shop and
uh of course you know they built the
gift shop later but but my question for
you is you know when you look at these
objects um you know when you find this
object you should go through the
calculations that led you to conclude or
in the government to agree with this
calculation that this was Interstellar
but then that you found in Papua New
Guinea around the most likely trajectory
Impact Zone you actually found these
Sphero is it a just so story is it just
like this gift shop appearing next to
the meteor crater in Arizona and if so
if not why let me let me explain first
of all from the crater you only infer
the kinetic energy the energy carried by
the object that impacted the Earth and
that doesn't tell you separately the
mass of the object and the speed that it
came at it tells you the product of the
mass times the speed square
and that's all that you can learn from
the size and the shape of the meat of
the crater so when examining uh impacts
on Earth we can't really tell where
these impactors came from we can't say
whether it's solar system origin or
Interstellar origin outside the solar
system what was special about the meteor
from 2014 is that the US government
satellites and other sensors detected it
when it exploded in the atmosphere and
could measure its speed and they measure
the speed of 45 kilometers per second in
some direction and we went back in time
and realized that it was not bound to
the sun it was moving faster than the
Escape speed from the Sun and moreover
it was moving very fast even outside the
solar system so we put that in a paper
and the paper was not published because
the referees argued well we don't know
the uncertainties in the government data
and obviously the government doesn't
want adversaries to be aware of the
census that it's using so it didn't
reveal the uncertainties and it took
them three years to end up confirming as
you said at the 99.99 confidence that
indeed the Aero budget is extremely
small which is what I expected because
they are responsible their day job is
National Security they have to figure
out if a ballistic missile is heading
towards Washington DC so they have very
precise data they put their reputation
on the line but I should say on the day
that we came back there was a paper
published in the astrophysical journal
by two astronomers who argued that they
are trying to fit the government data
with their model for Stony and iron
meteorites and they cannot do that and
therefore their conclusion was the data
must be wrong the speed that was
measured must be a factor of a few
smaller now the way I was brought up is
if your model doesn't fit the data then
you revise the model but instead what
they say quite arrogantly I should say
is the data must be wrong because our
models for solar system rocks do not fit
it well I said that long ago I said the
material strength of this object was
different than solar system rocks that's
why the models didn't fit it and just
think about the rotation care of the
Milky Way galaxy you might argue oh the
rotation cap of the Milky Way galaxy
cannot be fit with assuming ordinary
matter that we find in the solar system
and therefore the data must be wrong
well no cosmologists all over the world
for by now it's 90 years are worried
about what this matter might be they
call it dark matter that's the main area
of research with billions of dollars
dedicated to finding what the dark
matter is but if we were to use the same
logic we would say we don't see this
matter in the solar system as of now and
therefore the data must be wrong and you
know that kind of logic perhaps is
adequate for traditional fields that
focused on space rocks but
intellectually that's not suitable for
exploring the universe beyond the system
the solar system because we know that 83
percent of the matter in the universe is
of a substance that we don't find in the
solar system and moreover we launched
probes out of the solar system so why
not allow for the possibility that this
object may be a voyager from an
exoplanet if you were to take this
object in the serials
um how do you say it several spheroids
so let me explain these are just the
molten droplets from the surface of the
object that were melted when it was
exposed to the extreme heat from the
Fireball and the the fireball released a
few percent of the Hiroshima atomic bomb
energy
so I'm going to show on the screen from
your medium piece I'm going to show an
image of some of the uh the images that
you sent me
and including some of the microscopy and
so forth let me first show the boat and
show you on the boat with a magnet so
you can't see it but my audience sees it
it's from your from your medium website
so let me put that up on the screen now
so it says series of boats it looks like
it has a Gantry that you guys lifted
stuff on and off of talk about the
magnetic sled get into the details nerd
out with us please what is this black
sled what does it do yeah how could it
possibly contaminate what you saw are
there other systematics involved please
please explain right so uh we decided I
mean the ocean is uh has a depth of two
kilometers and think about it we're
trying to find droplets that are a
fraction of a millimeter across the
region that is 10 kilometers in size
that's the the region over which the
sphere the any droplets were spread from
the explosion and and then that sounds
like an impossible task but the idea was
to use a method that was tried before
and basically use a magnetic sled a sled
that is full of magnets on both sides
neody new magnets and we drag the sled
with a cable that was attached to the
ship to a winch and at first in the
first two days we had difficulties
keeping the sled on the floor on the
ocean floor because there was a force
the tension of the of the cable was
lifting it and the opposing gravity and
we figured that we had an exceptional
team of Engineers and people that are
the best in the world for ocean
Expeditions and they figure the method
of basically going with the current and
keeping the sled on the ocean floor so
that was in the first couple of days and
then we started collecting materials and
basically what we would do is lift the
sled you can see it in the middle panel
here lift it from a two kilometer depth
by the way the cable went five
kilometers because the sled was dragged
far away from the ship and and so we
would bring it back up after usually
eight hours when we were going over a 10
kilometer line and so we were basically
scanning in each run a line
whose length is 10 kilometers but the
width is one meter the width of the sled
the sled had a weight of about 200
kilograms and we added some lead at the
front of the sled there just to keep it
on the floor and so we started
collecting materials and the the most
common the most abandoned material that
was magnetic that we had to scrape from
the magnets was a volcanic ash it was
black powder and the what the way we
would approach it is once we put the
sled on on the deck we would remove this
material from from the magnets and put
it in vials or in a bucket and then
dried up from the water that was used we
would use actually later on a vacuum
cleaner to suck all the particles that
were on the magnets that was a very
effective method actually and then we
would dry them up and use a mesh with a
size that is a quarter of a millimeter
to separate the to basically filter out
all the tiny particles associated with
the volcanic ash and then we were left
with particles that are bigger than a
quarter of a millimeter and at that
point you know we didn't see anything
unusual by eye and I wrote an essay one
of my
36 diary reports it was after the the
sixth day I said where are the spherols
spheroles are these droplets that Mel
Health from the surface of meteors as a
result of the extreme heat that the
surface is exposed to and the we
expected them to be there and we didn't
see them at first by eye but then we
started looking in the seventh day
through a microscope and amazingly
enough the geologist on the team ran
down the stairs and called me and said
Avi we found a Sphero and I went up the
stairs and saw it on the digital display
of the microscope and I immediately
hugged the person who founded the Ryan
weed because I knew from my experience
in the kitchen I washed the dishes every
day I knew that if I see an ant in the
kitchen there should be many more ants
out there
so after seeing the first feral surely
enough within hours we find met we found
many more and all together about the 50
of them in the samples that we collected
over 26 runs right and then there is
more material actually that we haven't
had a chance to analyze for example this
material that I'm showing here that was
collected just a few hours before we
left and so we didn't have a chance to
analyze it so we have a team of people
here at Harvard and you can see here the
images
these ferals look spherical and they
have these beautiful colors of gold the
blue uh brown and black and my daughter
as soon as she saw it she said could I
have one on a necklace and I said well
these are half a millimeter in size it's
very difficult to thread them and so
what we are doing is looking at them
through an electron microscope and we in
fact we did that on the first day we
came back we landed at San Francisco
Airport and I went immediately with a
group of team members to UC Berkeley
where they have some electron
microscopes and mass spectrometers and
we looked at the images and amazingly in
one of the spheroes that was found along
the meteor path I should say most of the
spheroids that we found were along the
expected meteor path that we localized
by using seismometer data from Manus
Island in Papua New Guinea we could tell
the distance of the explosion from that
seismometer based on the time delay and
that gave us the most likely path to
within a kilometer and we found most of
the spheroids next to it and very few
spheroes far away like tens of
kilometers away so that is one
indication that these ferals are related
to the meteor and are not background
because when we went to very distant
Lines within fines ferals like that okay
and these ones are mostly iron and so
this paper that came out saying the
government data is wrong uh when we came
back also concluded that it's most most
likely not iron that this meteor is made
of and guess what they made this
statement in a published paper on the
day that we came back with materials
spherols from this meteor that show us
that most of it is iron and and that was
based on an X-ray fluorescence analyzer
that we had on the ship which basically
shines x-rays that penetrate the 100 a
tenth of a millimeter into the surface
of these ferals and excites the
electrons in the whatever atoms this
surface is made of and you can learn
about the composition from that you can
tell which atoms are there from the
spectral lines the fingerprints the
speckle fingerprints that these atoms
have and so that allowed us a
preliminary test of the composition that
indicated mostly iron in contradiction
to this paper
and moreover the fact that we found
these ferals next to where the
government said they the meteor exploded
confirms that the governor you know I I
sleep better at night I know that the
government has good sensors
now would the meteorite have uh
detonated an air burst like uh most most
you know Munitions would be detonated or
nuclear weapons would be detonated would
be have been an airburst event
yeah so there was a fireball which was
noticed by satellites and by
ground-based sensors and that's what the
US government used to infer
the properties of this meteor and there
was also a blast wave generated as a
result of the explosion that as I said
we we found the data from the
seismometer in Papua New Guinea that we
used to infer the distance and so it as
an explosion it was just like any other
explosion in the atmosphere and by the
way there is an atomic explosion energy
equivalent explosion just like an atomic
bomb every year by a rock the size of
emitter or two the size of a person
roughly that comes from the solar system
colliding with Earth every year every
year we have an atomic explosion in our
atmosphere but it's usually at very high
elevation 30 to 40 kilometers so we
don't notice any damage but every now
and then there is a one that gets closer
to sites where humans reside and you
hear about it in the news and by the way
this is the reason I noticed this meteor
historically I was interviewed about a
meteor that exploded above the Bering
Sea back in December 20 2018 so in
January the middle of January 2019 a
month later after the holidays uh there
was a radio station in New York City
that wanted to speak with me about that
meteor and I didn't know much about
meteor so I went online and I found this
catalog that NASA compiled of 273
meteors and I asked my student
undergraduate student Amir siraj to
check whether the highest the fastest
meteors in that catalog could have
originated from outside the solar system
just because I was intrigued by omuamua
that was discovered a couple of years
earlier and so he looked into it and
immediately Italy we found this meteor
that we call now im1 for Interstellar
meteor one and it was a complete
coincidence I didn't plan it I just
noticed this catalog and we looked into
it and then by now this is the site that
we visited and found sparrows from
when you were to look at uh say an
object that you can purchase uh say
online a meteorite you can cut them open
and you see these very very famous
patterns uh which uh their technical
name is called Whitman Statin patent uh
they're basically found in all metal
iron nickel objects so this would be
indicative of a natural formation I mean
this basically comes from the very same
meteorite you'll get if you join my
mailing list and you're one of the lucky
winners let me shrink that so we can see
each other
um so if we were to cut this in half and
treat it with some acids and so forth
you'd see this are these spheroles
expected to display the wooden Statin
patent patterns as well if they are
naturally occurring and others if
they're not technological in origin well
for the first question we're asking is
is the material different from solar
system materials okay and we can answer
that either based on the composition of
elements within in the spherols OR
radioactive isotopes because for example
in the UC Berkeley analysis of the mass
spectrometer we already found uranium
and lead and as you know uranium comes
in two isotopes 235 and 238 235 decays
into lead 107 whereas 238 decays into
lead 106 and by measuring the relative
abundance of these different isotopes
you can infer the age of your sample so
because the lifetime is different for
the different isotopes of uranium the
235 lives for 0.71 years the Giga years
billions of years and the 238 has a
half-life of 4.5 billion years roughly
the age of the solar system and so
that's a very good kind of clock that
can be used to infer the duration of the
journey and when I checked the two
swirls that were on the path of the
meteor it looked as if their age
estimate is larger than the solar system
but that's something we can do much
better with the analysis of more
spherols as we find radioactive isotopes
in them we can date them we can compare
the relative abundances of Isotopes to
those found in the solar system because
the solar system was uh you know
originated from a common cloud of gas
that was enriched with very specific
isotope ratios very narrowly confined
Isotopes for example of chromium or um
or iron and by studying the spherols
that we have we can differentiate
between them and solar system material
but beyond that if we demonstrate and
Inter first of all if we demonstrate an
Interstellar origin just based on
composition I should say this is the
first time that humans put their hands
on materials that are originated from a
big object that entered the solar system
that would resolve once and for all the
doubts that are being raised about the
intestinal origin irrespective of what
you think about the government's ability
to measure velocities if we find that
the composition indicates materials that
originated outside the solar system
that's it okay and that would be a
historic Discovery because it's the
first time a big object exploded and we
found the materials to be outside from
outside the solar system okay and of
course at that point there is a second
question could it be that it was an
artificial object that it was
manufactured by a technological
civilization just imagine droplets
melting off semiconductors or an
electric circuit they would have a
bonuses of rare elements that would be
very different than the abundances you
find in nature okay so in principle just
from the composition you can say
something about about the technological
origin but that's an indirect assessment
and a much better approach is to find a
big piece of this object lying on the
ocean floor and you can think of these
spherols as rose petals that
romantically direct you to your partner
which is the big piece left over from
the meteor so we know where to look and
that would be the target of a future
Expedition where we will use instead of
a sled with magnets you know that that
kind of sled cannot really pick up
anything big we will use an imager using
Sonar to look at objects at the bottom
of the ocean in the area that we suspect
the meteor may have landed and and if we
find it of course we could tell if it's
a rock or a technological Gadget because
a technological Gadget would could have
a label saying made on planet y it could
also have buttons on it and I asked
students in my class at Harvard and the
last class of the semester of the spring
semester I asked them if we find a
gadget and it has buttons on it should
we press a button
and half of the class said no way don't
do that because we are worried about
what may happen and the other half of
the class said oh we are very curious
why don't you press a button we want to
see what will happen and then one of the
students asked me what would you do
Professor Loeb and I said I would bring
it to a laboratory and examine it before
engaging with him
yeah or bring it to a rival University's
department chair and have her open it up
um okay so we have a lot of questions
from uh folks online and you have a
limited time because you're going to
Australia virtually in just a bit but um
but we have a question a couple
questions from David ax who's a
journalist with The Daily Beast he's
just asking you know what uh what's the
probability that it's not Interstellar
in other words they're the combination
of the spherols having another origin
and the uh a natural origin and the
combination of you the spheroes being
not related to the interstellar meteor
um and the the fact that the
interstellar meteor may not be truly
Interstellar we can't say 100 confidence
so if you add together these
probabilities apply the probability but
not being right so yeah so here is the
what we know uh first of all we know
that the velocity information about this
meteor indicated that the 99.99
according to the U.S space command that
it's in Interstellar okay so that's one
data point we have another one is that
we found most of the spheros near the
meteor path the likely path of the
meteor not far away and I'm talking
about a contrast by a factor of 10 or so
because in in one of the lines along the
meteor path which was perfectly aligned
with the meteor path we found 11
spherols and in background lines that
went to control regions we found that
most one to two
so to me that's an indication that we
were you know
bullseye on that particular run that
found 11
but of course you know it could be that
there was another meteor in that
location who knows but the chance for
that would be quite small
um yeah so rather than
quantify in terms of our ability all I
you know I'm explaining what is the
evidence we have but the best evidence
would be if we find isotope ratios or
composition in terms of elements that
clearly differentiates these ferals from
solar system spheros because there is
one based on the statistics there should
be one Interstellar object per thousand
of solar system objects of the same size
just based on the fact that Interstellar
objects were found once per decade okay
in the catalog of the NASA you know we
found this and another candidate that's
it over the past 15 years or so so um so
with that kind of impact rate and using
all the numbers we have we estimated
that one in a thousand is Interstellar
and that means that if you find an
Interstellar composition in other words
a composition that came from far away uh
you know that I would say the 99.9 that
would say it's Interstellar because only
one in a thousand of meteors should be
Interstellar and you find it just at the
place where this explosion took place
and the US government claimed at the
99.99 so I would say it would be very
certain at that point so I would just
wait a few weeks I know that David might
be anxious to know the answer quickly
but then you know we just need to wait
for the evidence that's the work of
Science and one thing I saw is that many
scientists prefer not to I mean first of
all they told me not to go there
and even though I you know I was doing
the heavy lifting uh so now they're
saying oh you found something else and I
say just you know relax sit back you
know in a few weeks we'll know why why
are you so happy to make negative
statements all the time
when you were on last time you gave one
of the great all-time quotes on the into
the impossible podcast you said the sky
is not classified you still stand behind
that but the sea floor is classified in
fact the Navy here in San Diego
classifies wide wide swaths of it
um have you dealt with any governmental
officials either in New Guinea or in the
United States or been contacted by any
people that you know dress even better
than you do with pens that click like
this to make you forget have you been
approached by governments because it is
a sensitive thing that involves sonar
multi-channel sensors multi-messenger
processes and Material Science and so
forth have you been contacted by any
governments that you can disclose first
I should say that finding the truth
about Interstellar space is easier at
the bottom of the Pacific Ocean two
kilometers deep then it is based on
government officials you know you can't
really I mean David grush came up with a
story we don't know it was just hearsay
we don't have have any direct evidence
however you know I came back with
materials okay so just to show you that
it's better to be a scientist than a
politician
uh science is better than politics but
do you doubt his story by the way I mean
are you skeptical of his claims gracious
claims oh no I'm not skeptical I'm
intrigued but on the other hand you know
I cannot just rely on hearsay the point
is if he were he himself was never
exposed to direct evidence so yeah he
doesn't claim to it right it's just
people may have fooled him and he may be
completely sincere but someone told him
stories that are not real you know
that's possible every anything to do
with humans providing the evidence you
know to me is can be doubted uh that's
why in science we use instruments we
can't write a scientific paper based on
what people say okay so that's different
from the legal system where you can put
a person in jail based on what people
say and we know that a lot of people are
put for the wrong reasoning yeah that's
why Galileo said uh
yeah coming back to your question yeah
um I got only encouragement first of all
the Department of Defense wrote this
letter to NASA which came to my defense
okay so here is a government
organization helping the scientific
process of supporting you know a
scientist who is interpreting their data
and I found that to be very generous on
their side they put their reputation on
the line they it was not part of their
day job uh anything to do with
Interstellar space has nothing to do
with National Security right and they
are paid to deal with National Security
so they took time away from their day
job and did that wrote a letter that
doesn't convince astronomers they still
can write a paper a few weeks ago saying
they don't believe the US government but
I'm saying the US government did an
effort here to help us and I listened to
them and the other thing I should say is
you know I received some emails uh
including from the Pentagon during the
Expedition saying great work keep up
with the science and you know
on the one hand I don't know if
government has any uh information that
is being hidden from us I don't believe
conspiracy theories uh but at the same
time I would say you know that doing
science the way it should be done by
collecting evidence is the way to expand
our knowledge of interstellar space and
frankly I don't care about whatever is
manufactured by humans and so if it says
made in China that's something that
Washington DC should deal with I don't
care about it it's as uninteresting to
me as a bird okay if I find it in my
telescopes cameras that we built at
Harvard University so I'm just trying to
follow what the science is all about
collecting evidence rather than having a
Prejudice rather than tweeting about
things that you believe in because
social media doesn't will not reveal the
truth it's the scientific exploration
through instruments collecting data and
that's the way you know cosmology is
done that's where I came from black hole
research is done that's where I came
from so I thought it would be a piece of
cake you know if there is data that
seems anomalous in this case just like
in the case of dark matter if you know
so I see omomoa not being a comet I
would say it's not a comet so what could
it be and then instead of the approach
taken in in the cosmology Community
where people talk about the nature of
dark matter in many different ways when
I suggested something different from
space rocks there was a huge pushback
and I don't understand that quite
frankly
So speaking of the government and so
forth there was a question from one of
my listeners I'm just calling up the
article that he posted for me by Douglas
Dean Johnson that non-earth a senate
intelligence Bill gives holders of
non-earth origin or exotic UAP material
six months to make it available to aaro
um all right what what does this impact
if any on the spheroles that you found
well this is really interesting uh the
first question is does government have
uh such materials and you know are they
related to a meteorite that they had
access to and but it doesn't say whether
these meteorites are natural or
technological in Origins so
um and six months is a long period you
know so what I can say is we already
have access to a meteorite that most
likely came from outside the solar
system we will find out what it was made
of and we will let everyone know I mean
so that's the beauty of science that it
deals with open
data opens knowledge and I'm not hiding
anything what you see is what you get
once we figure out the composition we
will let it out and by the way I spread
it among three Laboratories with people
that are that do not have any agenda
that are completely neutral to what the
data might bring uh these are experts in
studying meteorites and you know they
will just tell me what their instruments
find okay so it has nothing to do with
people and yet I see a lot of people
saying oh we think it's that we think it
that's not the way science is done it's
by using instruments we have the spheros
in our hands we put them under the
microscope the electron microscope that
can resolve scales of hundreds of atoms
you know and we are able to do Mass
spectroscopy that will give us Trace
elements down to a level of uh 10 times
10 parts in a billion or something you
know so we will do good signs out of
this and that's the way science is done
we have the instruments we're doing it
right now just sit back and relax okay
so all these people that want to say
something negative don't say it wait
until we come out with the results and
then we can debate what they mean it's
reminiscent of what the namesake of the
Galileo project this guy Galileo Galilei
said he said measure what is measurable
and make measurable what is not already
so on the issue of what I would say
provenance perhaps um on the in the chat
room is my good friend Kurt jamungal uh
he and I did a wonderful uh interview
with Jim semivan who's a former CIA
operative and a a very famous you know
musician Tom Delong of Blink 182 and
yeah he was in my mind credited with you
know bringing a lot of the modern
interest in UAP UFO type phenomena to
the Public's attention appearing on the
front page of the New York Times not too
long ago he's got his own to this Stars
Academy and so forth and but while he
was on the call and I hope to do a part
two with him uh and and hopefully my
good friend Kurt and other people that
are in this uh field because so much has
happened in just two years since we did
that interview less than two years but
on that call he said he has alien
artifacts uh including alien biological
specimens uh except he could not vouch
for the provenance he said the
provenance had interruptions in it in
other words he had not he couldn't
verify the chain of command going back
to the origin of where this object came
from and he admitted it it wasn't like
you know some gotcha moment he he
himself admitted it and I'd love to
follow up with him more on that but um
what about those who say well you can't
Avi vouch for the provenance of these
spirals either you you got them you
scrape them up maybe you know somebody
malicious you know planted them or how
what steps is uh are being taken to
ensure the provenance that there's no
molestation of this stuff that there's
no um that nothing gets in rejected
intersperse some some oil from a
technician's hand what steps to ensure
the uh the Integrity of these data
points are being taken
that was very important for me and a few
weeks before the Expedition I sent a
memo to all team members uh that nobody
touches the sample uh without my
permission okay and I just wanted to
maintain the Integrity of the sample and
when we uh I was on all runs you know I
was monitoring how we scraped the
magnets and it was all done straight to
a bucket that was immediately brought up
to the analysis room where it was dried
up the material was dried up and
filtered and uh we made sure that there
is no contamination whatsoever and I
should say that it's very difficult to
imitate material from uh you know
another planetary system or we should
see what we find in this composition but
you need to plant a rare elements at
some very particular abundance pattern
and we can easily tell if that was you
know played with and also to make those
just to give an example one of the
spherols that we looked at through an
electron microscope at UC Berkeley it
had those ridges on the surface that are
dendrites basically and from the spacing
of these ridges and by the way this is
half a millimeter in size but we could
see them very clearly
um and from the spacings you can tell
the temperature that was that this
material was exposed to during the
explosion and we can compare the
temperature to what we infer based on
the properties of this meteor there are
lots of ingredients that a lot of
details that you can find in this ferals
about in terms of their morphology what
they are made of for example we by
looking inside one of them we found
spheres inside spheres just like Russian
balls and the reason is that at first
these small smallest droplets the size
of a few hundred atoms condensed
solidified but then they were engulf
with molten iron and that glued them
together and then a bigger drop came
over and and got so to make such a thing
in the laboratory even if you are very
ambitious I think I would you know it
would be a very difficult task to make
it because you need huge temperatures
that are provided by atomic explosions
for example but we can tell the
difference between the droplets from an
atomic explosion based on the
radioactive elements and anyway there is
there are lots of details and we will
put them in a scientific paper to be
submitted to peer review and the way
science is done hopefully within a month
and so everyone will have access to that
and you know that that's the way you do
science I should say it gives them the
one thing I wanted to bring up is uh
this type of research gives inspiration
to artists because just a couple of days
ago there was a sculpture from Spain who
decided to build a giant sculpture
inspired by my research and also behind
me there is a letter that I received
from Alan Bergman who wrote The Windmill
of your mind and one four Oscars three
Grammys two
um I mean he all possible prices Awards
and he's writing a song for a play that
is almost completed about my research
with the hope that it will be presented
on Broadway and you know there is a of
course there is also the documentary
being made but I should say the public
at large is very inspired by first of
all the fact that this research
resonates with their interest so science
can be exciting that's my point science
can be exciting doesn't need to be
boring uh and it can also resonate with
what people want to know and then just
you know the fact that I'm funded
without
using the conventional pass of applying
to federal grants just from individuals
that come to the porch of my home and
provide the funding now that is an
illustration of how this subject appeals
to the public yeah definitely okay I
know you don't have that much time left
so let's do some quick lightning round
questions uh reminder you can always ask
me questions on Instagram or Twitter at
Dr Brian Keating Dr Brian Keating uh in
here in YouTube subscribers I'll try to
get to you first so I have one from Andy
mode I'll put that on the screen for one
such media Interstellar meteorite to hit
us there must be huge amounts of similar
objects passing through the solar system
can you subscribe yeah yeah no I mean
this object as I mentioned came from
behind us the Earth was orbiting the Sun
and based on the rate of impacts we can
infer that there should be a million
such objects at any given time if you
look now at the snapshot a million
objects half a meter in size from
Interstellar space within the orbit of
the Earth around the Sun now we can't
see them they are they are dark to our
telescopes because they don't reflect
enough sunlight we we could see or more
because it was 200 times bigger okay so
it had an area that is 200 square times
bigger than this meteor and the 200
square is a big number it's a it's four
times ten to the the four you know and
and that allows telescopes on Earth to
to see the sunlight reflected of an
object the size of a football field but
our telescopes cannot detect the amount
of sunlight reflected of a half a meter
sized object and we have a million of
those right now within the orbit of the
Earth around the Sun and so of course we
can design observing strategies uh
perhaps um you know going into space uh
that would be a very fertile uh field of
research in the future but what we found
with this Expedition is that um instead
of using telescopes to learn about what
lies outside the solar system we can use
microscopes that's a completely new
window into the universe so yeah and
then along those lines I'm going to Echo
a question posed by Echoes In Lo-Fi
um he or she is asking will Galileo
project be studying meteor fragments and
exotic metals found in the Unida Basin
and will you be collaborating with the
landowners other than Skinwalker uh let
me rephrase that question let me ask a
question a low-cost way to you know see
uh uh you know without going to the
Expedition on the ocean again I couldn't
go with you I get seasick on a on a
paddle board but I'm sorry I can't go
with you but um but just test every
terrestrial meteorite Stony metal test
every single object that you can get a
fragment of I'll I'll sell you one of
these you know for a Harvard t-shirt
maybe but um can we just go into the uh
you know Storehouse at Arizona State
University here is the interesting point
that once we understand what makes
something Interstellar in terms of
composition okay based on the analysis
of this meteor then we can go back to
reservoirs of meteors that we had on
Earth okay and check if any among them
could have been Interstellar in origin
based on our understanding of this one
and that would be a very interesting
thing to do because in the past when
people collected meteors they may have
classified a small fraction of them as a
rare class of space rocks that belong to
Earth to the solar system you know and
and perhaps as that small fraction
represents the small fraction of
interstellar objects that impacted the
Earth over the billions of years that
the earth existed so um yeah I think
that is a valid a very good question
that would allow us perhaps to identify
some small subclass of the meteor
meteorites that we have on Earth
as Interstellar okay now take some
questions from my audience on YouTube on
the chat comment section Avi can you and
please feel free to answer briefly if
you need to Abby can you please
speculate on why entities visiting the
Earth seem to be so interested in US
military nukes cattle that's from
Anonymous so um in this case of the
meteor I would argue that if it's a
technological Gadget it's not the
functional you know it's just like
Voyager would be in a billion years
colliding with an exoplanet so it's just
Space trash think of it as Space trash
just like the Plastics in the ocean you
know our civilization is producing
Plastics and by 2050 there will be more
mass in Plastics in the oceans than the
mass in fish so don't eat fish from the
ocean after 2050 because it may contain
a lot of plastic that's why Montgomery
Burns invented the Omni net on The
Simpsons many years ago okay Avi is
comes from Paolo de Sousa if the
analysis of the spherols and other
retrieved materials comes back as
natural materials are inconclusive will
the next expedition to the site of im1
be conducted anyway
no um I think it will happen if we find
it to be Interstellar otherwise there is
another candidate between Portugal and
the Azores that we identified and it's
another potential Target that the US
government did not confirm that one uh
so we have something to do no matter
what uh but let's see first what we find
from the composition yeah Okay then if
it does come back as interesting or you
know possibly
um uh valid to consider as an
Interstellar object and so forth uh when
this is from awaiting aliens 762 so 764
so don't think it's completely uh
impartial person but uh when they
they're asking when you go back next
year to look for a large objects what
will be the methods and tools and
technology that you would add to the
Expedition would you use the same ship
what kind of tools is in your dream
yacht besides the president of Harvard
you know providing one for you
no I mean we thought
about that already and thought that of
using a sonar that would have a
frequency of
um high frequency so that we can
identify
um you know if 30 kilohertz identify
rocks and separate them from anything
different
um uh and then we could also have an ROV
uh some Imaging device that is hovering
over the surface and Survey in the
region of Interest we have to decide
based on the amount of money that we
will have uh obviously if we find this
object to be Interstellar based on
composition we will have the money no
doubt
irrespective of how ambitious we are
because a lot of people would like to
know the answer so it all hangs on what
we might find and as I said I gave it to
Laboratories that I trust you know
whatever they deliver back I mean it's
not up to me and whatever they bring
back will be reported in the scientific
paper and we will know hopefully within
a month okay this comes from Mike 9678
what are your opinions on uavs or uaps
Etc are they from another planet what's
your most likely you know Bayesian sense
Avi what what if you had a you know
guess you put a gun to your head uh what
do you think they are
well so Sean Kirkpatrick in his latest
testimony to the NASA study committee he
said that you know only a few percent of
these unidentified anomalous phenomena
are truly uh anomalous that a lot of
them are presumably uh balloons you know
we saw the Chinese five balloon but
there are many more balloons uh or
drones or airplanes they can figure them
out and you know as far as I'm concerned
I mean of course for him it's very
important to make this assessment
because of National Security interest
that's why Congress funds Aero they're
all anomaly domain resolution office but
for me as a scientist I'm exactly
interested in the opposite uh in the
tiny fraction of objects that cannot be
explained and could be of
extraterrestrial origin and even if it's
one out of a thousand that would be of
great interest so in the Galileo project
we already have a functioning
Observatory and we are planning to make
more of them and in fact just before I
join mind you we had a conversation a
discussion within the research team of
the Galileo project about how to treat
anomalies and my view is if we don't
have good enough data we will simply
report
objects that we that do not cannot be
explained as a known type of objects of
like birds or balloons or so we will
just say that there are outliers there
are nominals we can't figure them out
but if we have good enough data for
example we have triangulation we have
information about the temperature of the
object the distance the speed at which
it was moving if we have a lot of
information then we could potentially
make a more significant statement that
it cannot be a human-made technological
Gadget and you know in that case if it
looks like a technological budget and it
doesn't seem to be human then it would
suggest an exothersology so all I would
say is we need to develop the
capabilities to figure this out using
instruments and you know there people
talk often about the Nimitz incident
where people saw some you know people
saw objects moving really fast and I say
if you go on a highway and you see a
black car in front of you and then you
see a black car behind you you might say
wow this car really you know was moving
really fast but it may not be the same
car
unless you have the license plate you
can't tell yeah absolutely okay Avi it's
coming to the end of the time that you
have before your next uh appearance
um and I want to just say that you will
be appearing on the podcast next month
for the release of this book which I am
devouring as we speak in all formats
that your publicity team has provided to
me Interstellar the search for
extraterrestrial life and our future in
the stars
um and the last question I have from the
audience has to do with the role that
the New Guinea government is playing are
you involved with them are you part are
they participating in any way do they
have provenance do they have access to
the samples what's their role
so we established a collaboration with
the University of Technology in Papua
New Guinea and in fact we have the head
of a department there
we are planning for him to visit us very
soon and be part of the analysis and we
share some materials and so we have a
collaboration uh with people over there
because what we
have I mean we collected 35 milligrams
of these spheroes this is really tiny
amount of materials but it's to be
shared with the scientific community at
large including with Scientists in Papua
New Guinea which we hope to get involved
with our analysis so
um and you know so all together we see
it as a collaborative project to advance
scientific knowledge it has no
commercial value whatsoever it was a
tiny amount of materials that we
retrieved and it's just elements laced
with fentanyl just tell them it's laced
with fentanyl you cannot get it well it
belongs to someone outside the solar
system you know and let's figure out who
that is yeah what if they say yeah you
have to return it to where where it came
from Avi what are you going to do then
is Harvard have the budget for that oh
actually my dream if you ask me what I
mean Elon Musk says that he dreams of
dying on Mars my dream is to board a
spaceship that will make it to another
planet and appear as a meteor in the sky
of that planet and then a scientist over
there would pick a particle of dust from
my body from the ash produced by the
explosion out of my body and I would
feel very honored to be studied by a
scientist on an exoplanet that would be
my greatest honor so just to summarize I
look forward to speaking with you again
in a month and hopefully then we will
know more about the composition of this
meteor so stay tuned and I'll be back
with more details all right we're going
to take us out with shooting star
by Bad Company wonderful song Avi thank
you so much best of luck
and have a wonderful summer Avi I'll
talk to you next month
thank you looking forward to it